dr anthony fauci says we might be
wearing masks into next year
the biden administration refuses to
condemn andrew cuomo's cover-up and
coca-cola is pushing racist diversity
training i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressivevpn.com here's the
thing folks i've been talking about
expressvpn on this show
four months why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet ladies and gents i will tell you
this there has never been a more
important time to protect your digital
rights
that's why i and thousands of my
patriotic listeners choose to secure our
online data by using expressvpn
did you believe a vpn isn't for you
because you can use the internet just
fine without one
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every site you
are visiting are you confused about how
it works
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones that encrypts your network
data and reroutes it through a secure
server that means you can use the
internet more anonymously without having
your activity tracked
do you think vpns are complex and only
for tech experts take it from me they
are not with expressvpn you launch the
app you tap one button and now you are
protected it is indeed
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they are
rated number one by cnet and wired they
stand for my values now is the time for
you to take a stance don't give your
data to people who really don't like you
very
much instead take back your privacy at
expressvpn.com get three extra months
free on a one-year package again
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get
three extra months for free
visit expressvpn.com ben right now
well before we begin i just want to give
you a quick reminder you should go check
out the sunday special we just did with
our friend
gina carano it really is i think quite
spectacular it is it is moving
and it is clarifying gina explains
exactly what went down at disney plus
and lucasfilm when she was fired from
the mandalorian and the sort of culture
that had been created there this this
woke culture
in which you were bullied and saying
things that you didn't actually believe
or silenced
it's definitely worth the watch so go
check that out over our youtube channel
or
download the show on our stream because
i think it is well worthwhile
okay on to the news of the day so
apparently we're gonna lock down forever
like forever ever ever ever there's
never gonna be an end to this that
apparently is the message coming out
from the biden administration and this
is the stupidest thing you could
possibly do at this moment
it is truly idiotic the reason it is
idiotic as i have explained before is
that vaccines are coming out these
things are basically a damned miracle
these vaccines are unbelievably good
these vaccines remove according to these
studies about 94 to 95 percent that
we're talking about modern or physical
94 to 95 of the deadliness of the
disease
and prevent you from getting the disease
in most cases in the first place
and not only that we now know that one
of the things that happens with the
pfizer and the bioentech vaccine
is that it actually does stop the
coveted spread which is perfectly
commonsensical okay when when you get a
measles vaccine you now no longer can
pass measles because if you cannot
obtain measles then you cannot pass
measles now there was this
bullcrap nonsense going around that you
would take the vaccine and then
you were still passing the thing or you
already had coveted and now you're still
passing the thing the evidence to back
that was extraordinarily scanty in fact
there was virtually no evidence to the
idea that after you had had kovid you
were still a major
cause of covet spread and yet that was
pushed out there as though that was the
apotheosis of science it was not it was
never the apothe it was never good
science forget the apotheosis of science
well now according to bloomberg the
pfizer and bioentech acie cova 19
vaccine
appear to stop the vast majority of
recipients in israel becoming infected
providing the first real-world
indication that the immunization will
curb transmission of the coronavirus
the vaccine which is being rolled out in
a national immunization program that
began december's 20th was 89.4
effective at preventing laboratory
confirmed infections according to a copy
of the draft publication that was posted
on twitter
and confirmed by a person familiar with
the work that means that not only are
you not going to die from the thing
you're probably not even going to get
the thing
9 out of 10 cases you are not going to
get the thing and even if you do get it
it's not going to be severe it's not
going to be life-threatening
the company's worked with israel's
health ministry on the preliminary
observational analysis
which was not peer review some
scientists dispute its accuracy the
results were also reported in der
spiegel in germany
they're the latest in a series of
positive data to emerge out of israel
which has given more code vaccines per
capita than anywhere else
in the world almost half of the
population has had at least one dose of
the vaccine
also israeli authorities said that the
pfizer bioentech shot was 99
effective at preventing deaths from the
virus 99 i mean the thing's a miracle
right
okay by the way quick side note here
there's an awful joke on snl that just
is rooted in a lie
i'm not going to say that the guy who
said the joke was anti-semitic because i
don't know his intent i do know
that the content of the joke is just
untrue okay the content of the joke
is that israel is discriminating against
arabs and giving the vaccine
no the palestinian authority is a
sovereign government it is their job to
get the vaccine they've not asked the
israelis to provide the vaccine
arabs who are living in israel are
getting the shots in the same way that
is the jews who are living in israel are
getting the shots so it's just a lie
anything else that you may have heard
along those lines in any case
the basic idea here to go back to the
vaccines is that these things are
unbelievably effective like incredibly
effective and by the way
they were being rolled out before joe
biden entered office joe biden jumped to
the front of the parade
and then he stood there pretending that
he created the parade okay this thing
was already underway operation warp
speed it helps create the vaccines
create the market for the vaccines
guarantee income from the vaccines the
rollout of the shots was already well
underway when this guy took office if
you look
at the pace of the rollout which really
began early january
somewhat mid-december to early january i
mean this guy got immunized
january 11th nine days before he took
office one of the things that you can
see
is that it is on a consistent upward
trajectory it's not like it was moving
at a low trajectory and then biden took
off and went
and just exponentially increased nope it
was always on this consistent
arithmetically increasing trajectory
okay so joe biden is just continuing to
lie about this he keeps saying that
there was no plan when they took office
and
it is of high irritation that the same
media that declared that every time
trump opened his mouth it was a lie
just refuses to acknowledge that this
administration lies like fury when it
comes to covid they lie repeatedly and
routinely about kovid
in order to cover for the fact that they
really didn't do anything in order to
cover for the fact that their plan has
been
meh basically the same as trump's plan
like today for example
there are a lot of stories out it'll be
a miracle if if joe biden is somehow
able to achieve 300 million shots by
august that'll be incredible why would
that be incredible we're rolling out two
million shots today you know what that
means if we kept on today's pace we
didn't even increase the pace if we kept
on today's pace that would mean
330 million shots by august so no that's
not a miracle in the same way
that joe biden came into office
promising a million shots a day and the
day he was inaugurated there were a
million shots
he's just lying about things here he was
lying over the weekend
about how there was no plan when they
took office which is obviously untrue
this this jerko was was vaccinated
nine days before he took office so what
was the plan bob
just over four weeks ago america had no
real plan to vaccinate most of the
country the hell are we talking about
my predecessors my mother would say god
love him fail to order enough vaccines
fail to mobilize the effort to
administer the shots
fail to set up vaccine centers that
changed the moment we took office
i mean come on that's just i'm sorry
it's just
not correct that's just not correct okay
so then dr fauci who again
i started off with the dr fauci is
trying to do his best
perspective now i just think that the
guy loves the spotlight and i think that
he's terrible at his job i think he's
absolutely awful at his job
because his job apparently doesn't
involve actual epidemiology anymore his
job basically involves going on tv and
saying a bunch of
conflicting things that make no sense to
the cheer to the wild cheers of the
media
right they set him up as this anti-hero
to trump because trump was captain
misinformation
but dr fauci has shifted his position on
every single issue in this pandemic he
shifted his position more often than the
kamasutra recommends it's insane
okay so now dr fauci is suggesting maybe
we should wear masks into 2022.
i have an answer for you dr fauci no
the answer is no once we're vaccinated
we're not wearing masks and guess what
we're not socially distancing we're
going back to ball games we're going
back to regular life we're eating
indoors and we're eating relatively
close to one another
because we can't live like this people
were not meant to live
like this and all you people in control
who think that you're going to maintain
control with the threat of the virus
no the answer is no okay so here's dr
fauci suggesting we're going to be
wearing masks into next year
and we've got the biden administration
saying by august we're going to immunize
the country
and then you're saying oh no everybody's
going to continue socially distancing
and wearing masks until
next year i cannot think of a message
less calibrated toward getting people to
do the vaccinations
seriously i'll explain why in a second
here's dr fafter just saying ridiculous
crap
do you think americans will still be
wearing masks for example in 2022.
you know i think it is possible that
that's the case
and again it really depends on what you
mean
by normality i want to see it go way
down
when it goes way down and the
overwhelming majority of the people in
the population are vaccinated
then i would feel comfortable in saying
you know we need to pull back on the
masks we don't need to have mass
okay so apparently forever apparently
forever i mean they've gotten to the
point where they're now arguing for zero
transmission
there will never be a point where there
is zero transmission of this disease
okay that's ridiculous it will be
seasonal
some people will die from it every year
the chances that it is going to be a
zero transmission
are extremely extremely low but here's
the thing when you keep saying things
like you can't go back to normal
and then you base it on unknowns in
science when we kind of know
all you are doing is encouraging people
to not get vaccinated and then guess
what
by the summer when transmission is low
people are going to go out and party it
up
seriously here are the two available
avenues in reality avenue number one you
tell people that after they get
vaccinated they can do what they want
right that's avenue number one and then
everybody wanting to get back to normal
goes and gets vaccinated because they
want to do what they want
that is avenue number one then there's
avenue number two people don't get
vaccinated because you
keep telling them that even if they get
vaccinated they can't do what they want
so they don't get vaccinated
then the half the population that gets
vaccinated is good to go
and by summer the transmission is down
transmission is already dropping
radically
okay transmission is way down by the
summer and you have a bunch of people
who have not gotten vaccinated
going out there and they're still not
vaccinated and then the winter hits
and then we get another round of this
and all those people who are not
vaccinated because you told them they
couldn't go back to normal life have
already gone back to normal life because
transmission is down
except they're not vaccinated and then
you get another uptick in the winter
so there's no third choice here by the
way people keep suggesting there's a
third choice the third choice is well
you know we tell everybody to get
vaccinated but they also have to lock
down for you you know who's not going to
do that
anyone with a brain because why would i
take the additional risk and annoyance
of getting a vaccine when i am young and
healthy if you're telling me i still
can't go back to regular life
you know what the chances of the chances
are of somebody who's 20 years old dying
from covid
extremely low like three in one thousand
very very very low
you know what the chances are after
getting a vaccine maybe one in one
thousand or less than one in one
thousand
so are you gonna take the vaccine and be
miserable for a few days in order to
lower your risk from three in a thousand
to one in a thousand or are a lot of
people who are young gonna go eh you
know what i'll just wait
or you could tell people you know what
to get back to regular life get the
vaccine
and then you know what people will do
they will go get the vaccine you know
how we know this because that's exactly
what israel is doing
right now israel has what they're
calling vaccine green cards
there are problems with this particular
strategy but it at least encourages
people to get the vaccine
right the argument that israel is making
is if you would like to go to this
restaurant if you'd like to go to this
bowling alley if you'd like to go to
this crowded scenario
get the vaccine that is a good public
relations campaign for getting the
vaccine because now there's an incentive
you notice a bad public relations
campaign we don't know
even after you get the vaccine you still
can't see your grandkids even after your
gran
your grandkids want to see you they
still can't see you even after they get
the vaccine and this is what dr fauci is
saying
he keeps saying this kind of crap over
and over he's so he needs to be fired
he's bad at this job he's bad at this
job
fouchy should again i'm not saying you
should've been fired while trump was
president i'm saying should be fired
while biden is president
biden wants to actually have some sort
of clear forward thinking standards for
how this stuff gets rolled out
here is dr fauci saying i don't want to
say grandparents can see their grandkids
after the vaccinate
then what the hell are we all getting
vaccinated for seriously what are we
doing here
here's fauci my parents have already
gotten their second dose
they're fully vaccinated does that mean
it's okay for them to spend time with
their grandchildren who obviously have
not been vaccinated
what's your recommendation you know i
i'm not going to make a recommendation
now except to say that these are things
that we really do i mean literally every
day
tano we look at that we look at the data
we look at
what's evolving about how many people
are getting vaccinated
and there will be recommendations coming
out i don't want to be making a
recommendation now
okay um but um you're on national tv and
you're asked a direct question
you know the answer to that question is
generally speaking yes
grandparents should be able to see their
grandkids after they get vaccinated that
is the point
of the vaccine it reduces death by 99
if you go to israel right now where
everybody above the age of 65
essentially
has now been vaccinated the death rates
for seniors are lower than the death
rates from covet for people who are 40.
okay so the answer here if you want to
encourage people to do the vaccinations
should be yes regular life awaits it is
right around the corner and yet they're
not doing this why because
at this point you got to say it's
because they want control they want
control and they are propagandists for
the idea
that you must continue to lock down an
abject fear of a disease that
post-vaccination is not particularly
dangerous
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact
that every responsible person should get
life insurance right on the off chance
that god forbid something should happen
to you you need to make sure that your
family is taken care of this is why
you need policy genius policy genius can
help you check off two big items with
ease you can compare life insurance
rates and say 50
or more in the process that means more
cash to put toward the things you care
about whatever that may be plus
there's absolutely no hassle their
licensed experts work for you not the
insurance companies so they can offer
unbiased advice when you need it
here's how it works first head on over
to policygenius.com in minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting at as little
as a bucket a you might even be eligible
to skip that in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they'll take care of everything for you
soup to nuts that kind of service has
earned the policy genius a five-star
rating across over 1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you're
worried that march is just around the
corner and you've barely gotten anything
done
take a deep breath policy genius will
help you make the most of this short
month in minutes you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes feel good
knowing your loved ones would be taken
care of if anything were to happen go to
policygenius.com to get started policy
genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice and
quite important to get it right
and so again although she is doing these
days is just going on tv and talking
about his uncertainty with regard to the
vaccine
this is the dumbest possible idea it's
unbelievably stupid
you need people to want to get the
vaccine
vaccine and when you talk about oh
they're all these coveted variants and
and they could sweep through the nation
yes that's true
and that's one more reason why you want
people to rush to get the vaccine now
and what we are seeing are high levels
of rejection one third of people in the
military bipolar
do not want to get the vaccine you have
extraordinary levels of vaccine
rejection in the black community
people saying they don't want to get the
vaccine because they've been told by the
media about the
tuskegee experiments in the 1930s and so
the idea is that the systemic medical
system is out to get you you got people
like charles blowing the new york times
justifying that kind of crap
the answer right now is we've been given
this miracle way out
there's the old jewish joke about the
guy who's drowning
and he calls out to god save me and sure
enough
here comes a guy in a row boat and he
looks down at the guy and he says
hop on in get into the boat guys no
god's gonna save me
and then five minutes later a helicopter
flies over and a guy repels down he says
come on up we're saving you he says no
god's gonna save me sure enough the guy
drowns he goes directly to heaven
and he says to god i don't understand i
prayed i had faith in you you didn't
save me
and god says who do you think sent the
boat in the helicopter okay the vaccine
is the way out and to not promote that
message is the height of idiocy
especially given the fact that what we
now see is that transmission rates are
dropping
like a stone remember when we were told
that tampa bay was going to be like the
center
of all kovid insanity remember this
after the super bowl
super bowl parties we're all gonna it's
two weeks after the super bowl you know
what's happened to the rates
all the rates are dropping the vaccines
are only going to make that better
now there's a problem okay the problem
is that if you have a bunch of people
who don't get the vaccine
because summer is coming and the
weather's going to warm up and the
transmission rates are going to go down
and then we get hit again within
december
then all those people are not vaccinated
so you know you should be telling them
get the vaccine
instead you got dr fauci out there
saying we don't know how durable the
vaccine is going to be
maybe you still need to wear a mask
maybe you should socially distance maybe
you should never see grandma again and
she should die
alone and lonely in a nursing home the
hell are these people doing
at a certain point you have to recognize
what they are attempting to do is just
control your life
because the science doesn't back what
they are saying the public policy
certainly doesn't back what they are
saying okay it's not just me saying this
if you like derek thompson from the
atlantic saying this
people on the left saying this okay this
is a mainstream
scientific view is that to encourage
people to get vaccines you have to tell
them that they can get back
to their regular life and yet you have
the entire biden administration
backed by the way by the american
federation of teachers saying no even
after the vaccines we can't back to
get back to regular life here is dr
fauci the great and sainted dr fauci
votive candle dr fauci the mother teresa
of the medical profession
out there saying you know we still don't
know how durable the vaccine is going to
be so why the hell would i take it then
seriously here we go there are two
scenarios the one you're talking about
about the pfizer giving one dose
and having a good degree of protection
versus what they're doing in the uk so
let me very briefly explain both
the fisa situation where they gave a
vaccine
and after a period of time at 15 to 28
days they had good protection
what we don't know and this is the risky
business about it
we don't know how durable that effect
is going to be okay so
again what is he trying to do here this
is the guy who by the way lied
to you he lied to you about masks why he
said he had a good motive right his
motive was he only wanted medical
professionals to have ppe
he said masks were not useful now of
course masks are the greatest thing
since sliced bread
masks are the most important thing could
ever do right when you wake up in the
morning you put on your mask when you go
to sleep at night you still keep on your
mouth you keep on the mask forever you
glue it to your face
you sew it in there or you physically
attach it to your body like bane from
the dark knight rises because that's how
important the masks are but at the
beginning
you're saying you didn't need a mask why
because he was telling the good lie
right the platonic lie to try and save
you
okay well right now even if he doesn't
believe it shouldn't he be out there
saying
that the vaccines help you so much that
you can get back to regular life to get
people to do this
instead you've got nbc new york
suggesting that you shouldn't shed your
mask after a coveted 19
vaccine quote you're vaccinated against
the coronavirus now what
don't expect to shed your mask and get
back to normal activities right away
that's going to be a disappointment if
not a shock to many people why
why well because the center for disease
control hasn't changed its guidelines
ooh the magical cdc
ooh you mean the cdc that actively says
that their school reopening guidelines
have been crafted in conjunction
with the teachers unions you mean the
cdc whose leader rachelle willenski was
tossed directly under the bus
the biden administration tossed her
under the bus when she said that
teachers don't all need to be vaccinated
to reopen schools
right then they're like well we don't
know she was speaking in her personal
capacity then they backed up the bus and
ran
back over her this is the cdc i'm
supposed to trust
these are the institutional scientists
i'm supposed to trust these geniuses
over at the cdc fauci can only point to
the cdc's recommendations which are so
far
mom about exceptions except except
exceptions for vaccinated people getting
together
what experts also need to learn the
vaccines are highly effective at
preventing symptomatic coping 19 but no
one yet knows how well they block spread
of covet again
we do they block spread of kovad really
really well
there are studies out of israel
demonstrating that this is in fact the
case
there is very little counter evidence
that people i mean as far as i'm aware
no counter evidence that there is a
significant mode of transmission via
people who have already been completely
vaccinated
the looming question fauci said during a
white house covered response briefing
last week
is whether a person infected despite
vaccination can still unwittingly
infect someone else studies are underway
to find out
and hints are starting to emerge fauchy
pointed to recent research from spain
showing the more coronavirus and
infected person harbors what's called
the viral load
the more infectious they are that's not
surprising as it's true with other
illnesses
yes but you don't get a viral load when
you're being vaccinated that is sort of
the whole point
okay this is all this is all counter
it's not just counterproductive it's
idiotic
and let's be frank about this douchey is
now doing the propaganda effort of the
biden administration in a way that he
wouldn't for trump
and i think rightly so again the science
should not follow whoever the
administration is the science should
follow the science
but here he is just doing propaganda on
behalf of the biden administration over
and over and over
again the the sainted the the incredible
objective dr fauci suggesting you know
when when kamal o'hara said that you you
should be vaccinated before we reopen
the schools
the teachers she didn't mean that she
she said it was a priority
then what what i mean that's literal yes
when she says it's a priority to get
teachers vaccinated before we open we
reopen schools
americans are going to think that means
the teachers have to be vaccinated
before we reopen the schools here's
fauci in full spin defense mode
for kamala harris with vice president
hammers said it should be a priority
she did not say it's a cna cuanon that
unless you get vaccinated
you cannot come into the school and
teach so what we're saying and let me
state it clearly because
i believe strongly that it is completely
compatible
with both with with dr walensky said and
what the vice
president said is that clearly we want
to make
the vaccination of teachers a high
priority
okay by the way we shouldn't we should
not
okay teachers should be treated the same
as every other employee in america there
is no evidence that teachers are getting
this thing an elevated rate above other
people
none none okay where are the studies
like a study showing the teachers are
getting this at increased rates anywhere
on planet earth
i have not seen any evidence of this
effect at all and yet the idea that they
should be prioritized above what people
who are 60
why why if they're above 60 in a teacher
they should get vaccinated because
they're above 60.
but if you're a 30 year old teacher
you're not in any more risk than
somebody who's a 30 year old grocery
store worker
or a 30 year old mailman or a 30 year
old anything else
it's just nonsense but again the
nonsense is all that matters for these
folks because it allows them an element
of control
when i say that dr fauci is doing
propaganda work on behalf of the
of the biden administration he is right
voucher was asked are we being too
too careful on reopening the schools the
answer obviously is yes
right the cdc the cdc standards do not
make any sense
the new cdc standards recommend that 99
of all school children according to jake
tapper on cnn
are in areas where the schools should be
hybrid or home
home learning only okay that is not even
close to what's happening now that would
mean reclosing 50
of schools that are open and yet you
have dr fauci
the greatest doctor of all time except
for dr joe biden saying
that we're not being too careful on
reopening i mean come on what no
us are schools being too cautious do you
think
and are there schools closed right now
that should be open
in person you know i mean obviously if
it's a very difficult situation to get
an absolute definitive answer what the
what the cdc
has tried to do is look at the risks
that you have
and try if you follow the cdc guidelines
to get the children back in school at
least with hybrid
and maybe even when you actually have a
an increased spacing
with them that you can get it in what's
called a decreased
capacity it's hard to say that we've no
it's not hard to say at all
schools around around the world have
been open throughout this thing
around the world particularly elementary
schools okay and all of this is just to
back the biden aft agenda that's all the
american federation of teachers
that's all this is jen saki
was asked about school reopening and she
said well even if there's vaccinations
even if there's funding even if there's
everything we might not reopen the
schools
because all they want is control folks
this is no longer i was willing to do
the good faith thing for about a year
we're a year in we're a year into this
pandemic and early on
remember i was an advocate for masking
throughout i'm still an advocate from
asking for people who have not gotten
vaccinated
and who have not had covet in order to
protect the elderly
right i gave falchi the benefit of the
doubt for a full year here
i i was even willing in the early days
to give the lockdowns the benefit of the
doubt at least for a month
six weeks okay before it became obvious
that the lockdowns weren't actually
accomplishing what they sought to
accomplish
because all they were doing was pushing
forward the infection into the future as
you see in new york
okay but you have jen sackey like at
this point i can no longer maintain the
pretense that there is no aspect of
political control being attempted here
here's jen sackey suggesting that even
maybe we'll never reopen the schools
maybe never maybe never maybe we'll all
just stay home forever
so a requirement you receive funding you
bring
you bring students back that that's not
a contingency that we're putting in that
we're recommending to go in
in the bill or in legislation john i
think what he believes is that
school districts working with our
secretary of education who we certainly
hope will be confirmed this week
need to make a determination about what
works best for them
based on these cdc guidelines or maybe
they should just make the determination
on what's best for them
along federalist guidelines as they
already have as opposed to the cdc
guidelines which are a bunch of crap
created by the aft they're nonsense we
talked about them at length last week
speaking of which my favorite here the
aft president is like you know it's a
great model new york city is a great
model where kids have been out of school
for like a year
randy weingarten on meet the press all
she cares about is the kids staying home
and teachers never having to teach other
than that she's great randy weingarten
by the way biden consider her for
secretary of education
there's no perfect solution but frankly
i think that new york city has done a
pretty good job
in terms of showing the way big school
district
lots of issues in terms of of
old buildings and we learned a lot
from what new york city did in september
and october and in fact
my members i just did a survey of my
membership
and 85 percent have said that they would
be
comfortable being in school if they had
the kind of testing
layered mitigation like you know and and
vaccine prioritization
and that's what new york city is doing
and vaccine prioritization you don't
need the vaccine prioritization
it's not true okay yeah i'd also be
comfortable going back to work if we all
lived in a plastic bubble and never had
to deal with other human beings
the data on elementary school
transmission demonstrate kids are really
not transmitting this to teachers in
large numbers
again i have yet to be made aware of a
single case in the i've been waiting
my email address is public b ship hero
dailywire.com let me know is there a
single case in the united states of a
teacher where it is clear the teacher
actually got coveted from a student not
from a fellow teacher not from a fellow
adult not from the grocery store at home
that a teacher got the disease from a
student and then died
i'm unaware of a single case in the
united states in which this has happened
maybe it's happened
i'm not saying that it hasn't i am not
aware of a single case if it has it is
extraordinarily rare
and yet the schools according to biden
and team should maintain
should continue to be closed you had
fouchy last week saying we need to pass
a stimulus package that's going to spend
tens of billions of dollars hundreds of
billions of dollars into the future
right into like 2024 in order for them
to open now
this is nuts and the media are just
going right along with it
there's an article today in the
washington post that is such like the
the alarmist propaganda
of the establishment media is insane
there's an article in the washington
post it is titled the youngest victims
of a national calamity and the people
they left behind
okay the entire article is about the
number of children who have died from
covet now here is the thing
not many children have died from covid
statistically speaking this is a disease
that is not particularly deadly in
children when i say not particularly
deadly i mean less deadly than the
fluent kids
well established that for young kids
this thing is really really really
not deadly at least not nearly as deadly
as the flu and we don't shut down all of
american life for the flu
obviously it is much more deadly for
people who are elderly
it is more deadly for people who are
above the age of essentially 20
but if you are below the age of 20 it is
not as deadly as the flu for you and if
you are below the age of 10 it is
certainly not as deadly as the flu for
you
and you have an entire multi-thousand
word article in the washington post
trying to scare parents
by talking about every single kid who
has died in the united states of covid
nearly three percent and three million
children in the united states have
tested positive
for the coronavirus about 12 of all the
cases
and the number of kids who have died is
extremely low
271 kids as of early february
out of three million children who have
had this
and those are the ones who've been
diagnosed and what we know about this
disease is that for every kid who's
diagnosed they're probably six to ten
who have not been so you're talking
about 18
maybe 18 million kids maybe 30 million
kids who've already had this and 271
deaths
every one of those is a tragedy but we
cannot pretend this is a national trend
worthy of a multi-thousand word report
in the washington post designed to scare
the living hell out of parents
that is not what media coverage is
designed to do unless it is what media
coverage is designed to do
in order to promulgate an agenda in just
a second
we're going to get to the media covering
up for andrew cuomo in a continuing way
and the biden administration covering up
for andrew cuomo it's amazing how the
worm has turned on andrew cuomo right
now we're allowed to make jokes on snl
about him a year ago he was the greatest
thing that ever happened to american
politics a year ago they were talking
about replacing biden with him on the
ticket
now everybody is pointing out the same
thing we have known for literally months
which is that he was lying overtly about
how many people died in nursing homes i
first reported that on this program i
believe mid last year
it was perfectly obvious he was doing
that because it would have made explicit
the fact
that his entire program was idiotic of
shipping coveted seniors back into
nursing homes
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that if you have a medical problem with
a simple medical solution why aren't you
just going and getting installed
this is why you need for hims.com your
one stop shop for hair loss and wellness
for men
hyms is helping dudes be the best
versions of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products to help treat hair loss
no snake oil pills no gas station counts
or supplements prescription solutions
backed by science
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier online than in person
instead no more awkward in-person doctor
visits no long pharmacy lines
four hymns connects you to a licensed
medical professional online and that
could save you hours it's completely
confidential it's discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you
you can prescribe your medication to
treat hair loss it's shipped directly to
your door and today
hims is giving you your best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund which
is a great deal and right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free go to for hymns dot com
slash ben that's for hims.com
male pattern baldness runs in my family
that's why i've talked to the people
over at for hims.com and you should as
well
prescription products require an online
consultation with a healthcare
profession provider who'll determine if
a prescription is appropriate
restrictions apply to your website for
full details and important safety
information
remember that is for hims.com
and go check them out right now okay so
now the worm has finally started to turn
on android cuomo we're finally allowed
to talk about the fact that um andrew
cuomo is a garbage governor who
got a lot of people killed with his bad
policy in fact there's a piece
in the week today by ryan cooper titled
resign andrew cuomo
he points out that his administration
concealed data about coronavirus cases
in nursing homes reportedly for fear of
federal prosecution
stories of his vitriolic abuse and
threats directed at other democratic
new york politicians are coming out yet
even all that is only the start of
cuomo's deadly corrupt incompetence
so in keeping with judging him by by his
results cuomo should resign immediately
and free new york state from his dismal
misrule says ryan cooper of the week and
not a right-wing outlet
the nursing home scandal has been
bubbling for nearly a year now it starts
with cuomo's inexplicable decision back
in march 2020 to order nursing homes to
accept recovering covet 19 patients
even if they were still testing positive
a recent ap investigation found that at
least 9 000 recovering patients were
sent back to nursing homes in long-term
care facilities
a number that is 40 larger than his
administration had previously admitted
is unquestionably worsened the pandemic
as it ripped through new york's elderly
population
that's not the only number cuomo fudged
on nursing homes new york attorney
general leticia james investigated the
situation
found that his people may have
undercounted the number of deaths
associated with nursing homes
by 50 cuomo then admitted that instead
of the 8 500 that they'd been reporting
the true number was over 15
000 about a third of the state's deaths
and then of course
the new york post reported comments from
cuomo's top aide melissa de rosa
seemingly admitted that they
deliberately faked the numbers as part
of a cover-up
his officials froze she said for fear
the truth was going to be used against
us
by federal prosecutors ryan cooper says
cuomo bungled the pandemic basically
from the jump the new york city metro
got hammered with the worst regional
outbreak in the country
in the following months cuomo's
compulsive bullying and control freak
habits gradually drove an exodus of
public health professionals from the
state government
including the state's health department
director of its bureau of communicable
disease control
its medical director for epidemiology
and the state epidemiologist
and then his micromanagement tangled up
the early stages of the state vaccine
rollout he threw out the plan the state
health department had worked up over
months
substituting his own he put in he put in
place strict requirements that only
people who qualified could get shots but
then added threats of punishments for
organizations that didn't distribute
their shots fast enough
and the result was chronic delays okay
so bottom line is this cuomo has been a
garbage governor and the media didn't
just cover for him they featured him he
was
the greatest governor in america
meanwhile ron desantis greatest villain
in america down in florida with the
number two population of seniors in
america by percentage after maine which
has seven people
okay so easily the oldest state in the
union if you don't count maine
florida and florida is ranked middle of
the pack in terms of deaths per million
like 27th
new york is ranked second new york was
treated as a wonder
a wonder of excellent management
meanwhile gensiaki over the biden
administration has asked
you know can you condemn cuomo covering
up these deaths and she's like no
no remember refreshingly honest
refreshingly transparent here at the
biden administration
is it it's amazing there's a lot of
dishonesty inside the trump
administration for sure
trump said things that were not true a
lot many of those things were
exaggerations or bloviation because
that's how trump was on a personal level
this is organized malicious and clear
lying
okay these are cover-ups by members of
an administration we were told these
were serious people okay
so i said throughout the trump
administration people kept saying you
don't treat him the same way that you
treat obama
you know when obama would lie you'd be
really on him and when trump lies you're
like yeah that's just trump
the reason b and i said yes because you
have to take into account
the nature of the people who are lying
to determine whether they are doing so
through carelessness which is mostly
trump or recklessness which is mostly
trump or whether they're doing so in
deliberate fashion in order to mislead
people
right in organized serious ways this in
this is an administration that in
organized and serious ways
covers up and lies to you here is jen
sackey pushing the cuomo cover-up
does president biden still consider
andrew cuomo the gold standard
when it comes to leadership on the
pandemic we work with governor cuomo
just like we work with governors across
the country he's also chair of the nga
so he's played an important role in
ensuring that we're
coordinating closely and getting
assistance out to people of his state
and to states across the country
but jen my question was does president
biden still believe that andrew cuomo is
the gold standard represents the gold
standard
on leadership during this pandemic
just a yes or no well john the president
the pres
the president well it doesn't always
have to be a yes or no answer
no it kind of does when you're asked to
direct yes or no question and especially
when the premise of the question
is very very obvious do you still think
that cuomo's done a good job
they won't answer the question of course
meanwhile the media in full spin mode
at least the fact checkers so here's the
thing about fact checking you have to
understand that what fact checking
really is that entire industry
is just laundering liberal opinions into
some sort of
faux objective standard that's all fact
checking is it's a bunch of lefties who
quote unquote
fact check you by checking your opinion
because they don't like your opinion and
then they say that you're lying and then
they ban you from social media right
that is what the fact checking industry
is here's a perfect example of it
at work angie dropnick holland is eic
she's the editor-in-chief of politifact
and just echoes andrew cuomo's lies
about the cover-up
i think the situation in new york is
really complicated oh
certainly there are things to criticize
about how the cuomo administration
handled data but the heart of the matter
goes back to last year when the state
was asking
nursing homes to take in patients covid
patients who are ready to be discharged
from the hospital
we don't see hard evidence that that
made a significant
difference in covid deaths okay we don't
see
uh any hard evidence that it increased
cover death so she's just buying there's
this mckinsey report
the mckinsey report was contracted for
by the new york state government
and the mckinsey report found yeah sure
we were shipping a bunch of olds back
into the nursing homes we had coveted
but we're going to say that it was
asymptomatic transmission
of healthcare workers that caused the
breakout in the new york old age homes
okay the evidence of that is
extraordinarily scanty you know what we
do know that when you send 9 000
old people with positive cova tests back
into nursing homes it might actually
increase transmission
okay but you got politifact just echoing
the bullcrap
unreal by the way the other person you
see on that split screen there is daniel
dale
one of the things you may have noticed
about daniel dale he was the cnn fact
checker during the trump administration
and he became famous for doing this very
nitpicky thing
where every time trump would speak he
would take every single statement and
then
he would analyze it down to the nth
degree like hair splitting so he could
call it a lie
so trump would say i have unbelievable
black support he'd be like he does not
have unbelievable black support
he has slightly more than he did last
time but it's not unbelievable unless he
is lying right it was that kind of crap
from daniel dale
now daniel dale has disappeared
according to mediaite
cnn fact checker daniel dale was one of
the busiest people in the cable news
business for several years
he has almost completely disappeared
from the network's programming over the
past month or so
what happened well since joining cnn in
june of 2019
dale has appeared or been mentioned on
the network more than once every other
day on average according to internet
archive
that exposure dropped sharply after
november 4th and according to the tvi's
media monitoring database
since joe biden's inauguration on
january 20th dale has only appeared on
the network
once that appearance last friday was to
fact check
donald trump's lawyers i wonder what
happened
why it's almost as though they only care
about fact checking when they are simply
attempting to check people
on the right amazing amazing okay we'll
get some more
media coverage of the biden
administration in just one second which
continues to be egregious sycophantic
and drooling
get to that in just one moment first
when it comes to staying in shape
nothing feels as good as the feeling of
accomplishment of hitting those fitness
goals and feeling great
about yourself i can tell you both my
wife and i have been
exercising and dieting really trying to
work on all of this since the beginning
of the year let me tell you something
that really helps us a lot echelon
echelon can get you there echelon offers
the next generation of connected fitness
bikes fitness mirrors rowing machines
and their echelon stride smart treadmill
no matter what your favorite fitness
activity
echelon will give you a fun challenging
workout from the comfort of home
the ex-7s it's echelon's latest state of
the art innovation it takes cycling to
the next level
the ex-7s connected bike is built with
performance
flexibility and durability in mind it's
the bike for competitors at heart
the world class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand studio level classes
always available when you need them
unlike their competitors echelon is
affordable for everyone
and one membership lets up to five
family members all work out at the same
time right now
you can try any echelon fitness
equipment at home for 30 days let me
tell you i am
super excited to be using the echelon
you've seen the other brands that do
this
way more expensive echelon is affordable
and it's great it'll get you into shape
and it's fun because i
i need to be involved in some sort of
class in order for me to really feel
motivated
to work out echelon knows that they make
it happen for you go to echelonfit.com
e-c-h-e-l-o-n fit.com
to get started already well yesterday i
had the privilege of sitting down with
the newest addition to our entertainment
team
gina carano this was her first sit-down
interview since she found out on social
media
she'd been canceled by the woke mob gina
is a real person
and this is the thing the folks on the
left want to treat her as some sort of
cardboard cutout
of an evil conservative and she is not
in any way that is perfectly obvious
from the interview they tried to ruin
her career and wreck her dream
and they failed check out the interview
if you haven't already tuned in join
the two million people who already have
at dailywire.com
because well we have a lot to talk about
and before going any further i want to
tell you all about a new series coming
out
this friday hosted by moa right this
only happens for our members
there's a simple highly effective rule
for making a good argument
don't build it on a fallacy this is the
first and really the most important rule
when it comes to developing a legit
argument
for some reason the left has decided
this rule no longer applies that is why
i will be exposing leftist fallacies
every friday in 15 minutes or less
exclusively for our daily wire members
exclusively you have to be a member on
my new series debunked
every single week i will take facts and
logic and own people with them we will
put them up
against a popular leftist argument the
kind you see your friends post and share
all over the internet and guys whether
it is climate change and ridiculous
solutions to it or universal healthcare
i'm gonna help you completely dismantle
the arguments being made by the left so
if you aren't already a daily wire
member head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off the first episode drops this friday
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe today use code debunked for 25
off we've been filming it it looks
fantastic and it's gonna be super
helpful
around the water cooler so you want all
the best arguments check out our new
series debunked by becoming a member
dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code debunked
for 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
one of the things that you see so
clearly right now is the media
continuing to just cover in every
possible way for the biden
administration it truly is
an incredible thing so the washington
post has a piece
today it is titled biden's low-key
approach to storm wins praise but courts
risks
now you will have noticed that ted cruz
was ripped up and down up and down for
not going and visiting
texas and handing out water bottles or
something instead going to cancun and i
said that's real bad optics right it is
bad optics
joe biden has been completely absent
like really absent he signed the
emergency declaration i believe over the
last 48 hours
okay and the take from the politics
section at the washington post
is that biden is doing amazing his
low-key approach to storm
wins praise by courts risks democratic
state representative james
talarico says the most he's heard of
federal help in his area during the
devastating winter storm is a female
water truck that apparently got stuck in
ice
kp george the top elected official in
fort bend county texas
said federal officials have told him
help is on the way just not fast enough
we can't wait another 72 hours to get
food and blankets and things like that
he said
and u.s representative colin allred
democrat of texas
said what would help most beyond an
infusion of federal dollars is a visit
from president biden
this has been something like the dark
ages here in texas allred said i mean
people are burning their furniture and
their fences for warmth and heat they're
finding older folks literally frozen to
death in their beds
when the president has toured seen the
damage spoken to the people who are
affected
i think that makes it a little bit hard
to say well i'm sorry you're going to be
on your own
as the biden administration faces its
first natural disaster says the
washington post
the president himself is taking a
notably low-key approach
he has not visited the stricken region
or delivered prime time remarks he did
not mention the disaster at a recent
town hall
and he is studiously avoiding the
controversy over whether wind energy or
fossil fuels are to blame for the
widespread power failures it's a marked
contrast to former president donald
trump
i mean i'm sorry you have ever so the
opening paragraphs are
every democrats like you know biden
should visit here and probably he should
you know meet with some people
and sign the emergency declaration make
sure the federal aid gets here and the
washington post is like
yeah so um he's asleep in his basement
and he's been catching all the latest
episodes matlock
but at least he's not trump what the
hell does it matter what like trump
hasn't been president for a month guys
like what are you talking about
they say he famously tossed paper towels
to hurricane victims excoriated
californians for gross mismanagement of
forests and called puerto rican leaders
corrupt and incompetent for their
handling
of aid money okay well first of all i
remember when you yelled at him for not
visiting the hurricane victims then he
went and gave paper towels to people
and then when he said that they
mismanaged their forests in california
that's because they did
as far as the puerto rican leaders and
their corrupt and corruption and
incompetence they found millions of
water bottles lying on the tarmacs
in puerto rico in the aftermath of the
hurricane so i mean there's something to
be said for at least part of that
response
but that's really not what the piece is
about why is trump relevant here
what like if it were trump we all know
what the headline would be right
trump refuses to go to hard hit texas in
the middle
of horrifying calamity i love this from
the washington post
while biden has won praise for his
quieter more business-like approach
he is also running the risk that he and
the federal government can appear almost
absent
state and local officials say a big test
will come in the months and years ahead
as texans replace burst pipes and
flooded homes
clear out dead crops and livestock and
investigate the collapse of an
electrical grid that left millions
shivering in the dark okay so i have a
question they've now said twice in this
article
that he's taking a loki approach and uh
he is receiving praise
for it so i'm just wondering where's the
praise they have
they've yet to cite we're not like 11
paragraphs in there's no praise cited
anywhere in here
about what exactly he's been doing but
according to the washington post
it is praiseworthy you have to get down
to paragraph you know 20 until you get
to this
the president this is uh daniel kanusky
a former female deputy
administrator said the president has
authorized fema to provide physical
resources
and financial resources just as
important officials said is what biden
has not done
several credited him with not
politicizing the disaster he has not
weighed in
on some texas officials widely disputed
claim that the failure of wind turbines
was largely
responsible for power failures well that
would be the smart thing to do right
because if he weighs in on that he's
going to be wrong
the president has also respond refrain
from scolding state leaders for
decisions relating to their power grid
that might have contributed to the
electrical collapse
well right because if he gets enmeshed
in that particular thing that is a
battle he is going to lose
nonetheless biden has been silent about
the storm since february 14th
you know what the headlines would be of
trump or silence about the storm since
february 14th right
he has tweeted that he and first lady
joe biden were keeping texas oklahoma
and other impacted states in our prayers
officials say it is a marked difference
from trump okay so here is the deal
no matter what joe biden does the media
will say it is the greatest thing he
wants to keep schools close it's the
greatest thing he's going to
be really wishy-washy about the vaccines
greatest thing he's going to roll out
the vaccines greatest thing he's not
going to mention what's going on in
texas amazing he is going to mention
what's happening in texas unbelievably
good
all great okay because bottom line is
this
for the media that has an agenda the
only democrat whoever gets criticized is
one they have lost use for
andrew cuomo can now be duly tossed out
of the boat because andrew cuomo is no
longer useful
if you look at biden biden is still
useful
maybe there will come a point where he's
no longer useful but for the media
trying to generate a narrative the only
good democrat is a democrat who is
useful
and when a democrat becomes not useful
that's when you can report on him you're
allowed to report on hunter biden after
the election you're allowed to report on
erdogano
after the election you're allowed to do
all sorts of these wonderful things
as soon as the time for actually doing
them when it would have made a
difference
what is over yeah there's such a thing
as a lie by omission and when your media
ignore major stories for a year
in order to prop up certain politicians
and then as soon as those politicians
become a liability
they immediately just stab them directly
between the shoulder blades at that
point you might start to distrust your
institutional media
amazing amazing stuff alrighty meanwhile
woke idiocy continues to be the rule of
the day
so i've said before that there is a
feeling in the united states and it is
not an unjustified one
that your employer is looking over your
shoulder
that you don't feel free to say what it
is that you want to say and that if you
do say what it is you want to say that
you might be fired
you can see that this is happening on
virtually every cultural level from all
the major
corporations it's it's pretty incredible
how political
all of american life has become i have a
bevy of stories about this today
so coca-cola has now decided that they
are going to
force their employees to take
anti-racism training
with the excremental robin d'angelo
robin deangelo is
the worst public intellectual in america
she's awful she's a cult leader
if you read her book her garbage book
white fragility
the entire argument that she makes is
that black people cannot take care of
their own future
that white liberals like robin d'angelo
have to take care of black people's
future that black people by dint of
being black
are systematically discriminated against
and that white people who fail to
recognize this suffer from white
fragility the only solution to which
is to listen to robin deangelo on what
she tells you the only way that you can
clear yourself
of the racist of the racist
drippings that that have adhered to you
is by taking a 20 000
diversity course from robin to angelo so
coca-cola duly did this because this is
what corporations do corporations are
afraid of
liability they're afraid that someone
will sue them for discrimination
and so they hire people like robin
d'angelo
to give them the cover to continue to do
business
they feel like okay fine so for 20 grand
now i can say when i'm
when i'm sued by some upset employee
that we gave everybody the anti-racism
training okay so robin d'angelo was
doing this training and we have some
screen caps
from this particular training here are
some of the screen screen caps
confronting racism understanding what it
means to be white
challenging what it means to be racist
solid stuff here from
robin to angelo okay to be less white
okay so here's how right we don't want
you to be white we want to be less white
which um okay this isn't racist at all
by the way
to be less white is to be less
oppressive be less arrogant be less
certain
be less defensive be less ignorant be
more humble
listen believe break with apathy
break with white solidarity now we need
to take a moment here to explain what
exactly robin deangelo is saying
again this is coca-cola employees being
subjected to this overt racism
because if you're white this means that
you're oppressive arrogant certain
defense of ignorant humble
you must not humble you need to be you
need to listen and believe
you're apathetic and you have white
solidarity if you're white so you need
to be less white
i don't know how like really how are you
less white
she doesn't mean that you color your
skin obviously that's racist instead
what she means
is that you have to be a a person who
listens to robin d'angelo
you are by being a white person
oppressive
unless you recognize that you're
oppressive in which case you're not
you're less white
in some way you're arrogant if you're
white despite you might think of
yourself as not arrogant wrong
wrong because now you're engaging in
defensiveness
right this is the stupid little game she
plays it's perverse game
right she says you're oppressive and
you're arrogant and you're certain about
all your stuff you're like well no i
don't feel like i've oppressed anybody
and as far as arrogance i mean frankly
i kind of know what i'm good at and what
i'm not good at and i'm not good at a
lot of things
and i'm not super certain actually in
fact i have a lot less certainty than
robin d'angelo
so i kind of deny this stuff and she
goes you're being defensive
right if you fight back against her now
you're defensive which means you're
being white again
stop that you have to be less ignorant
right because you're ignorant because
you're white you say well no i'm not i'm
not ignorant actually i know a lot of
things nope
there you are being defensive again you
need to be more humble
which um i love that just to fill out
this slide she had be less arrogant and
also be more humble
which is the same thing you have to
listen and believe
listen and believe okay if i listen and
believe she means that if someone tells
you
that they feel that they have been
subjected to some sort of predation by
another person
you can't evaluate the evidence you
can't say okay well i understand you
feel that way
the feeling may be authentic but what is
the evidence to back whether the feeling
is justified
authentic and justified are two very
different things a lot of people feel
things authentically that are not
justified by the underlying fact pattern
this happens all the time
my kids feel authentically angry at me
on a variety of bases that does not mean
that their feelings are justified
my son yesterday was time for him to go
to bed and my son
decided that he did not want to go to
bed right
and he was very angry at me because i
said we have to stop playing legos you
need to go to bed his feelings were
authentic they were not justified it was
time for him to go to bed
by the way he was so upset at this that
he then went and peed on the floor
because this is what children do funny
now wasn't it
it wasn't at the time his feelings were
authentic peeing on the floor was not
justified in any case listen and believe
is what robyn d'angelo says you must
believe
you have to break with apathy because
what she means by break with apathy
is you just have to mirror everything
she says or you're apathetic and finally
you have to break with white solidarity
because you understand
if you refuse to go along with what
she's saying this means that essentially
you're a white solidarity supremacist
okay then here's more from robin
d'angelo training the uh the unlucky
suckers over at coca-cola
in the u.s and other western nature
nations white people are socialized to
feel that they are inherently superior
because they are white
research shows that by age three to four
children understand that it is better to
be white
oh is that what the research shows is it
now
huh interesting also um
white people are socialized to feel they
are inherently superior because they're
right actually no the civil rights
movement
socializes to believe that people should
be treated as individuals
it is your educational training that
makes white people feel that they are
superior because it is only white people
who can solve the problems for black
people
that's something shelby steele pointed
out in his own book white guilt
which is one of the beautiful things
about being somebody like robin d'angelo
is the only person who can solve the
problem
is white people you still get to be
superior for if you're robin deangelo
you still get paid 20 grand to fix
america's racial problems
because you're owning it you see and
finally
try to be less white
honestly this should be like the 1984
apple commercial
just robin d'angelo talking to you like
big brother until somebody comes in with
the
with the race with the with the logic
hammer and flings it at the screen
try to be less white okay so coca-cola
a massive company hired robin d'angelo
to teach this crap
to the people who work at coca-cola yes
your corporate overlords they are
willing to buy into this stuff
now question why are they willing to buy
into this stuff the reason they're
willing to buy into this stuff is for
really three reasons one the people who
are buying into this stuff do so
because they're afraid of boycott and
they're afraid really of publicity
they understand that if you are
perceived as a liberal corporation fewer
people are going to come after you
right that is that is a rationale for
doing this
there's a study i cited it before from
harvard business review it showed that
if you put together a focus group
of of people from all different
political sides of the aisle
and you ask them about a corporation and
you ask them about the corporation being
formed in three different ways one as a
politically neutral corporation
two as a political politically liberal
corporation and three as a conservative
corporation
the crowd's reaction be wildly different
if you just said same corporation it's
neutral people are like okay sounds good
if you said it was liberal people are
like okay sounds good if you said it was
conservative
the positivity ratings dropped by 33
percentage points all among people who
are lefty
coca-cola understands this if they are
perceived to be the lefty corporation
they understand that people on the right
will still buy coke and people on the
left will be more apt to buy coke unless
they opt to go after them so that is
reason number one reason number two
it shields them from liability and
reason number three
because most of the people who now run
these corporate boards are people who
are liberal they have no systemic
intellectual defense against the hard
left
people who are liberal and innately
believe in the guilt of the united
states but they also believe in certain
individual rights
the problem is if you believe in the
innate guilt of the united states and
the innate evil of the united states
it's very hard to also believe
in the goodness and rightness of the
individual rights upon which the united
states is predicated you can't both
believe
that america's ideas start in 1619 and
that america's ideas start in 1776.
these are mutually exclusive beliefs
so you gotta pick a lot of liberals are
picking 16 19
because it makes them feel better about
themselves okay so that's what's
happening over at coca-cola and this
sort of stuff has infused
so many different corporations you see
it obviously over at disney
and not only did disney plus lucasfilm
decide to fire gina carano for no good
reason simply because she didn't go
along
with the woke left but now they've
decided to hit the muppets
with an offensive content label now this
was the most predictable thing in all
the land
they announced that you'd be able to
watch the muppets on disney plus
i immediately tweeted out that within
three weeks the swedish chef would be
canceled
it was perfectly obvious i was wrong it
didn't take three weeks it took three
days
disney has now slapped the muppet show
with an offensive content disclaimer the
muppet
show if you're sitting around getting
offended by
the muppets let me suggest you need to
get a job
you need to get a life have children be
a productive member of society you're
sitting around being offended
by muppets truly
like that that is incredible stuff
muppets from 1987
that's what you're getting offended by
you're not even watching new episodes of
the muppet show
and by the way the stuff that you're
getting offended by is not robin
deangelo spouting racist bull crap the
stuff you're getting offended by is like
fozzie bear told a joke
what the disclaimer shown prior to every
episode warns viewers the show features
stereotypes and quote mistreatment of
people or cultures
this program includes negative
depictions and or mistreatment of people
or cultures these stereotypes were wrong
then
and are wrong now rather than remove
this content we want to acknowledge its
harmful impact learn from it and spark
conversation to create
a more inclusive future together says
the disclaimer no no no
no rather than remove the content you
want to make money off the content let's
all get real here
you want to make money off the content
while dissociating far enough from the
content that you can claim that you're
not making money off the content
because it's all about the money making
it is
unclear exactly what disney considers to
be offensive on the show
some characters have depicted native
american middle eastern and asian people
their muppets the warning also appears
in front of bambi
well not not bambi right bambi's okay
cause it's just about deer right
aristocats
dumbo peter pan and of course swiss
family robinson
all great movies all apparently
unmentionable
hey and then you've got cartoon network
now pushing anti-racism okay
so so you've got robin's angela not just
teaching coca-cola but mainstreamed into
cartoon network now it's one thing to
get mad at the muppets from 1987 for
telling a joke
that you now consider culturally
insensitive 30 years later it's another
thing to get mad at cartoon network
when cartoon network is literally just
putting out psas
mirroring for children mirroring robin
deangelo's talking points on racism and
indoctrinating kids
into overtly racist garbage here is the
cartoon network pushing
what is obviously racism well i'm not an
alien but it definitely matters to me
that i'm black
yeah it makes a difference that i'm
white i know the two of us get treated
very differently my experience with
antsy black racism is really specific
other people of color experience other
forms of racism too
but you won't see any of that if you
don't see color can we get a rewrite
where we appreciate each other without
erasing what makes each of us different
okay but it's gonna add a couple hours
to the shoot i kept my doors open
uh you were rolling just now weren't you
can't we just slap some graphics on this
and call it a day
hmm see color be anti-racist
shut up racist children see color
be anti-racist so yes we are all
supposed to see each other
as people of different colors whose
experiences are completely
non-understandable i cannot
understand your experience in any way
and because i can't understand your
experience this is the robin deangelis
stuff i have to listen and believe
i can never try to assess whether your
opinion on a matter
is non-factually or evidentiarily based
instead i have to listen and believe
because you see
i see color so i'm an anti-racist which
means i have to listen and believe
whatever you say and presumably accept
all of your policy recommendations as
well
in order to destroy the systems of power
this is being taught
to children at cartoon network to
children
yeah you wonder why people feel like
they're under assault because they're
under
they're under assault here's another
great story this one courtesy of the new
york post today
a veteran bronx superintendent once
praised by chancellor richard camaranza
for her successes in the classroom
claims her career was career was
derailed by his equity agenda
forcing her to take a demotion in a
desperate bid to preserve her pension
according to a 150 million lawsuit
this fif 150 million dollar lawsuit
karen ames is a 30-year department of
education employee she said she was
targeted by karan's disrupt and
dismantle campaign
to oust or marginalize long-time
employees because she is over 40 and
jewish
the agenda of chancellor karanza and his
senior leadership team was
euphemistically touted as an equity
platform right we've talked about the
difference between
inequality and inequity and how the left
conflates the two inequity meaning that
everything is unfair
and any element of american life where
an outcome is not equal means that
something unfair happened
she says in reality the equity platform
was a platform
used to create gender age racial and
ethnic divisions in the new york city
school system
ames was grilled about her ethnic
background chastised by a
colleague at her training session when
she shared her grandparents experiences
during the holocaust in poland
and admonished when she declined
requests at superintendent meetings to
take part
in the comic book movie inspired wakanda
forever salute to black power
she charges in the legal filing carranza
had heralded ames success in raising
math scores at struggling schools
but instead of celebrating ames work
cheryl watson harris coranza's top
deputy who left last year to become
school's chief into cobb county
georgia interrogated ames to go during a
chauffeured car ride
about her department of education
history her family residency
and improperly inquired about her
ethnicity she claimed
at an implicit bias workshop where
superintendents were asked to tell their
personal stories
ames talked about her grandparents loss
of two children during the holocaust
only to have colleague rashida amon
teller you better check yourself the
lawsuit alleges
this is not about being jewish it's
about black and brown boys of color
only court papers quote amman is
scolding see color be anti-racist guys
it's so nice in august 2018 ames was
summoned to the department of education
headquarters where watson harris handed
her a termination letter
telling her the department was moving in
a new direction a month later
ames was given a choice take a demotion
or be removed from the payroll in 24
hours
she took the motion the doe eventually
assigned aims to the office of school
health but gave her no work for five
months
so um i'm con so they got they got angry
at her because
she wouldn't give the wakanda forever
salute wakanda is not a real country
gang
it ain't real if you refuse to give a
salute to a country that doesn't exist
is that racist apparently the answer is
yes
this sort of stuff is happening at
employers around the country around the
country
and you are allowed to target people at
these at these places
you are encouraged to target people at
these places
barry weiss formerly of the new york
times has an excellent piece today
about a woman named jody shaw at smith
college
she says courage has come in the form of
a woman named jody shaw jody shaw was
until this afternoon a staffer at smith
college in northampton massachusetts
she made 45 000 bucks a year less than
you than the yearly tuition at the
school
she's a divorced mom of two kids she's a
lifelong liberal alumna of the college
she has a front row seat to the
illiberal neo-racist ideology
masquerading as progress
in october 2020 after shaw felt she had
exhausted all internal options she
posted a video on youtube
blowing the whistle on what she says is
an atmosphere of racial discrimination
at school
i asked that smith college stop reducing
my personhood to a racial category
stop telling me what i must think and
feel about myself stop presuming to know
who i am
or what my culture is based upon my skin
color stop asking me to project
stereotypes and assumptions onto others
based on their skin color
now she's resigning from the college and
she's turning down a settlement that
would have given her a much
easier way out she says that the climate
at smith college changed dramatically in
july 2018
when the culture war arrived on campus
when a student accused a white staff
member of calling campus security on her
because of racial bias
the student who was black shared the
account on social media and drew a lot
of attention to the college
before even investigating the facts of
the incident the college immediately
issued a public apology to the student
placed the employee on leave and
announced its intention to create new
initiatives committees
workshops trainings and policies aimed
at combating systemic racism on campus
there was an independent investigation
into the incident and found no evidence
of racial bias
the college ramped up its initiatives
aimed at dismantling the supposed racism
that pervades the campus
this only served to support the now
prevailing narrative the incident had
been racially motivated and smith's
staff are racist
she was told that she was basically her
career was ended
why because she was supposed to create a
program
about library orientation in which she
used rap but because she was white
that could be viewed as cultural
appropriation she was up for a full-time
position in the library
she was told her candidacy was dependent
upon her ability
and she was told to reinvent a program
that she devoted months of time to
creating
and so she moved into a current lower
paying position as student support
coordinator
and then she was told on multiple
occasions discussing her personal
thoughts and feelings about skin color
was a requirement of her job
she says quote i endured racially
hostile comments
was expected to participate in racially
prejudicial behavior as a condition of
my employment
i endured meetings in which another
staff member violently banged his fist
on the table chanting
rich white women rich white women in
reference to smith alumna
i listened to i listened to my
supervisor openly name preferred racial
quotas for job openings in our
department
every day i watch my colleagues manage
student conflict through the lens of
race projecting rigid assumption and
stereotypes on students
thereby reducing them to the color of
their skin i'm asked to do the same
this woman at smith college she says the
last straw came in january 2020 when i
attended a mandatory residence life
staff retreat focused on racial issues
the hired facilitators asked each member
of the department to respond to various
personal questions about race and racial
identity
i said i don't feel comfortable talking
about that later facilitators told
everyone present
the white person's discomfort at
discussing their race is a symptom of
white fragility they said the white
person may seem like they are in
distress but it's actually a power play
in other words because i am white my
genuine discomfort was framed as an act
of aggression i was shamed and
humiliated
in front of all of my colleagues and so
eventually she quit
okay this sort of stuff is happening at
corporations all over the united states
it's happening at colleges it's
happening at coca-cola it's happening at
disney
it's happening in cartoon network it may
be happening where you work unless we
get together and we fight back against
this and there are many ways to do it
which we'll be discussing in future
episodes
and in my new book which will be coming
out shortly unless we fight back against
this it's going to win
we're all going to have to unite and
fight back against this you're listening
to the ben shapiro show
make sure that later today you check out
the michael muller show he discusses the
vatican mandating the vaccine you can
hear more details about that story over
on michael's show that is available
right now also
this wednesday february 24th we're
supposed to have a backstage
it's going to be magical mystical
experience i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pava wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
a corporate training enjoins employees
to be less
white joe biden writes off china's
genocide of the uyghurs as a cultural
norm
and dr fauci won't let you hug grandma
check it out on the michael knoll show